this video is sponsored by scentbird and
also i decided to put the ad read at the
very beginning of the video i think for
the first time ever just because this
video is so personal that it kind of
felt odd to put it anywhere else so here
is simba scentbird is a fragrance
subscription service just like netflix
allows you to watch hundreds of
different titles scentbird gives you the
opportunity to receive cents from over
600 brands in just a few clicks it's a
flexible subscription so you can skip
months if you need to and you get to
choose a new fragrance to try every
month for just 16 basically like your
personal portfolio into the world of
smelling good which let me tell you big
thing in australia men and women in
australia always wear perfume always
wear cologne loads of different scents
and they smell amazing way less common
in the us unfortunately i come from a
country where you remember people by how
good they smell not as much of a thing
here and i miss it get on board and if
you didn't already know if you're not
already somebody who's into smelling
super nice perfume can cost like five
hundred dollars for a bottle with that
bird you can get a luxury fragrance for
just seven dollars using my code i have
marc jacobs catherine molandrino prada
and get a room here like i literally
have prada here i've never owned
anything prade in my life look at me go
so yeah it just twists up like that so
obviously something you can easily carry
you spray it my whole
it's a lot there's a lot in there they
give you the whole vial
uh-huh oh this one's
damn
it's a convenient carry case but it's
still not like one of those tiny little
rollable samples it's it's a usable size
okay they're all very good they're all
really really really nice
so make sure that you use my coupon code
to get 55
off of scentbird that'll be just seven
dollars for your first month huge thank
you to scentbird for sponsoring this
video back to the video i'm very excited
about today's video i'm like nervous
so
uh on the 20th of march 2017
i made a video that is private on my
channel it's called time capsule
a very real video for myself in five
years
it's five years later i
am going to watch this video that i made
for myself
five years ago
i feel like i remember like
asking myself some questions
i didn't know if i would even still be
making youtube videos um i feel like i
always expected that i wouldn't and then
maybe i'll make another one if i'm still
making videos in five years i'll do it
again
i'm like
yeah
so obviously i've not watched it at all
in the five-year period i do not
remember what i said none of it um
i'm gonna watch it and i guess react to
it that's me five years ago before i get
comments about it no that is not my
natural hair color anytime people see me
with brown hair they're like i always
forget what your natural hair color
looks like you have never seen my
natural hair color that was dyed in any
case let's watch it i guess okay let's
do it great solana i'm alana and if
you're watching this video then it means
five years has passed and you are now
making a reaction video oh my god
i forgot that i used to do that i used
to put
like all my social handles on the top of
every video and this was edited in
imovie
my eyeliner was so bad okay okay i am
you're right younger olana and you are
now making a reaction video this is a
time capsule where i'm going to say
everything that's going on in my life
right now and then i'll ask you some
questions and if you're still making
youtube videos in five years i am
hopefully you will respond in theory you
are 28 and i cannot
[Music]
where you are
this is really weird right now i am in
the house that i share with three other
people in the san francisco bay area i
like this room it's cool it's 360 games
here and xbox one and ps4 games and
we have a whole new console generation
now baby we got whole new consoles
it's come so far
you do you were there you were there
with the 360 yeah so um i lived in my
friend's basement
three other people they had a cat that i
was very allergic to
um
i now live by myself
i have my own office
it's not in a basement
i was okay with that room you know but
wow that's
that's a lot of growth and collectibles
here we still got this i just got back
from an insane very quick uh work trip
to las vegas where
i recorded some
crazy [ __ ] for my job at ign that's
where i work i'm currently an associate
editor at ign entertainment specifically
uh covering toys and culture so on a
work front uh i do a lot of cool stuff
i'm having a lot of fun i get to travel
a ton i should be going to germany later
this year which i'm crazy excited about
that's for games coming august i do that
i love that i get to do that stuff but
it does come at the expense of
overworking i work way too much right
now
that hasn't changed my love that has not
changed no more traveling we don't go
places anymore sweet 2017 alana
definitely still overworking
which is probably worth reflecting on
it sucks a bit to consider that i was
criticizing myself for it then and that
i probably thought
she'll have this figured out in five
years she won't still be overworking in
five years
guess who's still overworking and will
be in five years who am i [ __ ]
kidding hopefully that's all paid off
though and well it has 28 i have a job
that i like and i'm in a better
financial position than i am right now
you are personally you are
you totally are that's so cool to see i
was so [ __ ] poor
jeez that i mean i wasn't that
so many people had it worse off than me
but
like i was struggling to
like
eat at this point it was very much
paycheck to paycheck like zero dollars
in my bank account frequently that was
only five years ago and now i do not
have those financial struggles i'm in a
position where i'm able to
support my family which is super
important to me yeah i've grown a lot in
five years yeah it has paid off i
[ __ ] love my job
i
younger orlando i'm a video game right
at sony santa monica studio which is
what is my background which is very
different to your background
obviously
um not a ton of stuff going on i feel
like my life is very drama-free still is
dating someone for just over a year uh
it's a long-distance relationship he
lives in austin texas and
due to how busy i am uh i think that
kind of works perfectly but also the boy
that you're dating is pretty great uh
are you still dating him
i am not still dating that boy no
my sister is currently organizing her
wedding she's supposed to get married
next year
she's like kind of locking in a venue
now i spoke to her just a couple of days
ago about bridesmaid dresses because
you're a bridesmaid which is super
exciting i keep swapping between i and
you and it's confusing even me but me
too the same person it's fine and on
that note
sorry if you watch this sarah
but i kind of feel like your sister's
probably gonna have a kid pretty soon
after getting married so maybe
five years from now i will be an aunt
that's so cool
yeah you are an aunt now
and it's very cool she's so cute that is
a weird thing to think about that's also
like an exciting thing to think about
mum and john
and your dad are all pretty happy and in
good health dad's working a little bit
too hard right now still true but he is
coming to visit soon i'm super excited
and then mom's coming to visit later
this year um
same thing this year so i guess i want
to ask like are you where are you living
also i feel like my voice is deeper
which is interesting my voice is deeper
my guess is actually that that is the
result of
i used to ham it up
so i used to try
to um
sound a little bit more feminine and now
i don't try uh i also am way more
expressive or maybe i just i'm noticing
it more because the lighting's worse or
something i feel like the old videos are
more expressive and my eyebrows are
terrible um anyway i live in los angeles
california
are you still in the us are you still in
i am cisco no where do you live l.a
there's like places that i've theorized
that i could live i've thought about
london and i thought about new york i
wish
she's obviously a little bit older but
is she still like just as excitable
that one sucked um
no
chelsea was my chocolate labrador
who i loved
she died when she was four
but mom and i got tattoos for her i
don't think i've ever shown this on the
internet i don't really share my tattoos
with the internet because i'm like i'm
gonna do it for you
like
well i'm not
in the habit of showing you my body but
um i did get this little tattoo for her
right there that i designed
that my mom and i got matching
no chelsea uh died um
probably not that long after this video
was made maybe six months later
um
she got in by a tick
and was dead within 24 hours it was
[ __ ] brutal
um she was on all the right medication
and it happened while my mom was
visiting actually
my stepdad had to
kind of
deal with that by himself
australia man to just [ __ ] insects
out there just do [ __ ] different and
yeah it sucks because that dog was like
so beautiful
however i am now
fostering dogs i fostered um one very
anxious lady named queen bee
and i'm currently fostering a lady who
is nowhere near as anxious for a much
shorter period of time whose name is
athena who's actually quite chill but no
chelsea is not with us anymore and it
sucks to to to
to know that i never would have guessed
that because she should still be alive
is trump still president
no trump is not still president
thing to look back on retrospectively
this is like well it's hard to say
because obviously this is my first time
living in the us but it feels like he is
one of the most controversial presidents
ever and i wonder if in five years it
will still feel the same way i guess for
other personal stuff um i don't have a
ton of friends in the bay area right now
because i'm so busy i don't really care
but i hope that that's something that
you work on eventually i do like most of
the time i remember initially finding
that really hard when i first moved it's
hard to get to know people it's really
hard to
make friends when you're an adult
i would say right now i have a lot of
friends and they're all really wonderful
that's definitely changed a lot in the
last five years for sure yeah i'm
that i have spare right now i spend a
lot i spend sleeping i spend playing
games in my room and not talking to
anyone because i just work so much that
i just feel the need to recharge all the
time and i just i don't feel like that's
the case anymore no
i spend a lot of time alone
because of my day job
but i spend my off hours being super
social these days like for an introvert
i'm a lot more social than i would have
expected i'm around people a lot
um
i don't even remember feeling that way
like enough that i would think about it
but i guess that's true you know when i
think about
that period of time where i lived in the
bay
um to begin with that i i did just spend
weekends like asleep i was still pretty
unwell then too because of um chronic
fatigue which only got worse over time
and
yeah i really did just spend a lot of
time in that dark basement just by
myself i really did
don't even want to be around humans i
hope that you're not still at that point
no i'm pretty social goals like i want
to host one of the major conferences one
day i still haven't done that that's
still a goal
i would still
really love
to host
uh
like at like an e3 press conference 100
i would love to and
it seems very unlikely now because of
where i work i'm doing a lot of awards
presenting that's a thing that i wasn't
doing five years ago where i i'm a
person that's asked to give awards at a
lot of major conferences but
baby e3 doesn't even exist anymore
maybe we didn't accomplish that one
maybe that one's maybe that's a bucket
list item we cannot check off i don't
know what i don't know if that's like
the game
wait i can take it back i'm hosting gdc
next week
i'm hosting gdc next week
oh you're okay yeah no you're fine
you're hosting gdc next week
you dumb [ __ ]
still in the process of getting tattoos
removed right now they're not completely
gone and i want one more tattoo i think
only one i think i want it on my left
foot i know exactly what i want but i'm
waiting for like
a big
life moment i'm waiting for something
that
is so huge that i feel like i want to
remember it forever
that i want to stamp after that happens
so that when i look at the tattoo that's
what i think of oh what's your hair
color i'm planning to dye this awful
[ __ ] white tomorrow brown looks nice but
it just it just gets oily so fast it's
i've been saying that for such a long
time okay people accuse me of lying like
why do you dye your hair that color it's
because my brown hair is so oily she
said it too it's true
my hair gets so oily when it's brown and
it like ruins my skin so you got to put
some bleach in that so that it doesn't
ruin all of your skin but uh thank you
there are people that i'm interested in
like where's max right now what's max
scoville doing with his life
max scoville still works at ign
just had a baby
he had a whole baby
around the same time that your sister
did
where is andrew who's hosting podcast
beyond
andrew goldfarb works at sucker punch
entertainment still one of my best
friends i sent him
a birthday present last week um little
pokemon jacket he's in seattle uh who's
post hosting podcast beyond
you know i don't know very quick change
of scenery because my light just broke i
want to contextualize this video
in what games are out right now because
i have a habit it's a great idea in game
releases two periods of time you've been
playing the absolute [ __ ] out of the
legend of zelda breath of the wild
pretty sure it's one of the best games
ever made correct
here if you still think that yeah mass
spec andromeda is just about to launch
and you're very worried about it you are
this [ __ ] i swear to god she was right
it's bad the game was bad currently
trying to get through horizon zero dawn
in the time that you can pull yourself
away from zelda and it's amazing redhead
redemption 2 is coming out later this
year mario odyssey looks really good how
did those turn didn't reddit two get
delayed that did not come out in 2017
right i don't think that came out in
2017. all right you guys and future self
that is it from me i look forward to
making a video about this video in five
years time
bye-bye
wow
oh my god that was so weird that was so
weird and
like bizarrely emotional i'm gonna do it
again because it was very cool
like
i recommend doing that for yourself
i had no idea what i was gonna talk
about
um
wow yeah
thank you for watching this video i
really feel like i made this more for me
than for anyone else
for a bunch of reasons so sorry
this was weird to watch
just nuts
very bizarre but yeah very very cool to
have gone from like such a low-paying
like literally lived in a basement
associate editor at ign
to working for one of the biggest game
studios in the world
in in a [ __ ] cool office you know in
five years
that makes it feel like so much longer
than it was in my head
like a lot has changed in five years
and in my head it's all a lot more
compact than that that's that's just
nuts
how cool wow
um all right thank you all so much for
watching thank you to scentbird for
sponsoring this video
i'm alana
i will see you in five years i'm gonna
make another one to put up as private
pretty soon
okay bye